- All right, hi everyone.
Thank you so much for
joining our parent webinar
on how to create a schedule
for your third through
fifth grade student,
as well as how you can use Khan
Academy resources and tools
to support your child's learning at home,
so you can keep your day moving.
I wanna take a moment to say
thank you to our sponsors,
including Bank of
America, Google.org, AT&T,
and Novartis for helping
us provide this support
during school closures.
Their support has made webinars,
and resources like this possible.
I also want to acknowledge
all you parents,
grandparents, older siblings,
and maybe even some teachers
who have joined us today.
Thank you for taking
the time to learn more
about how you can keep your
child learning at home.
We are so grateful you're
turning to Khan Academy
during these challenging times.
My name is Shannon, and
I'm a former teacher,
currently working on the
District Partnerships team
at Khan Academy,
and I'm so excited to be joined
by two of my colleagues and friends,
Dan who is on our marketing team,
and Patty who works with me
on the District Partnerships team.
Patty will be answering your questions
throughout the webinar,
so please submit any questions you have
throughout the presentation
in the question box,
and she will get back to you there.
And we'll also save about
10 minutes at the end
to answer your questions live.
Today's webinar will cover how to find,
and utilize content on Khan Academy
during the school closure period,
as well as tips and best practices
for setting up a daily
schedule for your child.
This will hopefully be helpful to parents
who are looking for ways to
keep their child learning
during school closures,
and provide some structure,
so that you can gain back time in your day
for all the many tasks I'm
sure you have on your list
beyond child care and homeschooling.
This webinar will not cover
in detail account setup,
or how to get started on Khan Academy.
So if you're new, our
Remote Learning Guide,
Quickstart Guide, is
a good place to start.
If you go to the handout
that's linked in this webinar,
you will see on the slide we have linked
the Quickstart Guide, so you
can check that out there.
Now, for a bit of
background on Khan Academy.
We are a nonprofit organization,
and our mission is to provide
a free world-class education
to anyone, anywhere.
Our content is standards aligned,
and available in over 40 languages,
covering multiple content areas.
Your child can access
our resources on the web
or through a mobile device.
With more than a billion
children worldwide
being impacted by school closures,
we are experiencing soaring
demand for our free resources.
We will continue to produce webinars
and resources to support remote learning,
So keep checking back to khanacademy.org
for any upcoming webinars,
and new resources as they are created.
And now let's take a
look at what resources
are available for your child.
Khan Academy is possibly best known
for our math content and math videos.
But in addition to math,
we have a full range
of subjects and increasing
range of subject areas.
For your elementary school student,
relevant content might include
our English Language Arts content,
which is in a work-in-progress state.
You can expect to see
it change and evolve,
as we continue to gather feedback.
We also have a mastery
enabled grammar course,
which covers third through
fifth grade grammar standards,
a computer animation
and storytelling course.
Both of these course were
created in partnership
with Disney and Pixar,
and are highly creative.
They involve computer-based
and tech free activities.
We also have a computer
programming for beginners course,
and Growth Mindset
activities for all ages.
These activities offer
students an opportunity
to reflect on their learning goals,
and develop learning strategies
that will likely benefit them
as they adjust to their new
learning routine at home.
Of our third through fifth grade content,
one important thing to know,
is only math and grammar
are mastery enabled,
meaning students can work
through an entire year's worth of content,
and at their own pace,
and track their progress along the way.
You might be wondering, well,
how do I access this content?
And the first step is to ensure
that your child is logged in
to their Khan Academy account.
And from there, and as you
can see on the right side,
you go up to Courses,
and that will bring you to the menu
displaying all content on Khan Academy.
And your students can
access any exercises,
quizzes, unit tests from there.
But you have another option.
On your child's homepage,
they can select Edit
Courses to access content.
And one benefit to
adding courses this way,
is it will automatically recommend courses
based off their grade level.
So you can easily find what content
is relevant for your child,
and once they've selected
and saved those courses,
it will always appear on their homepage,
so it will be easy to access for them.
And during this time of school closures,
we've heard so much feedback and questions
from parents and teachers,
about how to structure a student's day,
and keep the child learning,
while still getting your own work done.
We know how challenging it can be
to juggle multiple priorities,
and we hope that our
resources can help you achieve
some semblance of
normalcy during this time.
And in response to this feedback,
we've created this set of schedules
that give you a recommendation,
or you can think of it as a starting point
for structuring your day.
Using the link on this page,
you will see a template
for the daily schedules
which go all the way from
pre-K to high school.
So if you have younger
students or older students,
you can see the schedules there.
We put these schedules out,
having heard that there was a need,
but it's important to acknowledge
that they won't just work
as-is for all families.
You know your child best,
so we encourage you to adapt
and change the schedule,
to make it work for you and your child.
And in our sample schedule
which you see here,
the subjects outlined in green
have resources available for your child
on the Khan Academy.
Your child's school might already be
providing remote learning
guidance or tools,
or the schedule might not work well
with the routine you've
already established.
So know our sample schedules are meant
to be flexible and adaptable,
to meet the needs of your family.
You might not be able to stick
to the schedule every day,
and that's more than okay.
During these challenging times,
everyone is just trying to do their best,
so if all you can do is an hour of math,
and an hour of reading
a day with your child,
that's great, and that's enough.
When you and your child are ready,
you can always add additional subjects,
or activities that might
interest your child.
For a quick run-through of the
sample schedule we have here,
we'll start our day with breakfast,
followed by math.
Some outdoor play if possible,
or maybe a board game with a sibling,
followed by English Language Arts,
some silent reading time,
grammar, and then end the day
with some fun enrichment activities.
Now we're gonna go through
each part of this schedule,
and talk about what
resources you might use
from Khan Academy.
So starting our day like I mentioned,
first thing to do is eat some breakfast,
the most important meal of the day,
and get out of your pajamas.
It's time to get started with math.
And depending on your child's grade level,
second through fifth grade
math is likely a good place
for them to get started.
To move through the content more quickly,
students can utilize
our Course Challenges,
and Unit Tests.
One practice we've seen effective,
to fill in learning
gaps that your child may
have developed over the years,
is to have students start at kindergarten,
and work through the content
for each grade level,
before moving onto the next.
This provides students a rare opportunity
to fill in those gaps
that might hold them back
in the future.
If your child doesn't have too many gaps,
it can typically get through
previous year's content
in one to three hours.
And for a quick overview
of our math content,
here are the most important
things you need to know.
Our math content is aligned
to Common Core standards,
and it covers all standards
from kindergarten up to early college.
All math content is mastery enabled,
so students can work
through an entire course
at their own pace.
As your child works through a course,
they will be exposed to
various question types,
receive instant feedback,
and if they get stuck, they have access
to step by step solutions,
videos, and articles.
So before asking you for help,
encourage them to check
out the learning resources
that are built into Khan Academy.
Students can also track their progress
on this course in realtime,
and as a parent, you
can track their progress
on your parent dashboard.
We recommend giving
students ample time to play,
and get their heart pumping.
After a break, students can jump
into our English Language Arts content.
You can expect to see more content added
to each grade level over the next month.
You can have your child
start at grade level,
and practice one to two
practice sets per day,
which should take about 20 minutes.
If you notice the content is too easy,
or too challenging for your child,
you can have them move
up or down at any time.
And our ELA content is aligned
to Common Core standards.
Right now, our content includes practice
for second through eighth grade standards,
with ninth grade coming soon.
The content is focused on
reading and vocabulary standards.
As students work through assignments,
they will be exposed to
interesting passage topics,
related to science, social studies,
and social emotional learning.
And similar to our math content,
students have access to instant feedback,
and a worked rationale
for every answer choice
if they get stuck.
Our English Language Arts courses
have a limited number of videos,
but you can expect to see more added soon.
Another option for your child
during the English Language Arts block,
is to check out our project-based,
Imagineering in a Box course.
In this exciting course,
made in partnership with Disney,
students will create a theme park
of their very own, by getting
a behind the scenes look
at how artists, designers,
and engineers come together
to create theme parks.
The course includes videos and articles,
and activities, such as designing a menu,
creating a ride simulator,
and building a prototype character.
The course is broken down
into three main lessons,
with each lesson taking
a minimum of two hours.
So one option, if you
wanna implement this course
with your child, is to have them work
through the lessons for about 30 minutes,
one to two days per week,
in place of their English
Language Arts content.
And now we have arrived
at silent reading time,
which your child is likely used to having
in their regular school day.
We have listed popular
books by grade level.
You can see the link here,
but encourage you to have
your child find something
that they're interested in.
And after silent reading,
you can take a quick walk or break,
and then your child can jump
into our grammar content.
We recommend having your students start
by taking the course
challenge a few times,
to figure out what they know,
and what skills they
still need to work on.
And similar to our math content,
our grammar course is
also mastery enabled,
so your child can work through the skills
at their own pace, and track
their progress along the way.
The course covers skills related
to third through fifth grade,
standard American English standards,
and every question has
a step by step solution,
and aligned video to help support students
as they work through the skills.
And then for some tech free time,
which is so important.
Have your child take some time to journal,
or respond to a writing prompt.
This could be as simple
as having them write
about their day, and how they're feeling,
or you can have them create a story
of their very own.
On the schedule you'll see
some sample writing prompts
you can pull from, but feel free
to make these up on your own,
or encourage your child
to make up a prompt.
You can follow up writing
time with some lunch,
and maybe an educational podcast.
Podcasts are a great way to
keep your child learning,
while reducing their time spent
staring at a computer screen,
and it also might give
you back a bit of time.
There are a ton of great
podcasts for kids available,
and we listed some examples,
but encourage students to find something
that they're interested in.
And we'll end the day with enrichment.
Some options include
Code.org's Express course,
which is the block based
coding for beginner's course,
where students will create
their very own story or game.
And on Khan Academy, we also have
a text based computer programming course,
computer animation course,
which was created in
partnership with Pixar,
and Growth Mindset activities
for elementary school students.
And if you have an upper
elementary school student,
so a fourth or fifth grader,
or maybe you have a middle
or high school student,
and they're interested
in computer animation,
you can try our interactive
computer animation course.
The course demonstrates how
traditional school subjects,
such as math, science, and the arts,
are a vital part of the everyday work
put into Pixar's filmmaking process.
In this course, students will
work through the many stages
of the filmmaking process,
including lighting, effects,
and set and staging.
Similar to other content on Khan Academy,
students within this course have access
to instant feedback on exercises,
step by step solutions for
every question they answer,
and instructional videos to
guide them along the way.
This content spans multiple grade levels,
so not every lesson is appropriate
for your fourth or fifth grader,
but within the course, you
can access a lesson finder,
and find content that's
relevant for your age,
for whatever grade level
or age your child is.
And lastly, our research based
Growth Mindset activities
are especially relevant
during this challenging time
of school closures.
The activities provide a structured way
for students to explore the science
behind their brain, and the idea
that they can learn anything.
The Growth Mindset videos, and articles,
and activities cover topics
such as the brain and learning,
how to work through
mistakes and frustration,
and how to set goals.
With students adjusting
to their new remote learning routine,
these activities will provide a way
for students to process and
reflect on their new normal,
and set goals for learning remotely.
And if you're just getting started
with remote learning with your child,
and are looking for more tips,
and best practices to support
them and their learning,
see the link for more information.
We held a webinar last
week that covered a lot
of tips for effective remote learning,
so it might be worthwhile to check out.
And again, I just wanna
say thank you so much
for joining us, after what
I'm sure was a long day,
and I'll be turning it
over to Patty and Dan
for live Q and A,
so if you have any further questions,
you can reach out in the chat box
for the next 10 minutes,
but if you have any questions after that,
reach out to our Help Center,
and feel free to share this presentation
with any other parents
who might find it helpful.
Thank you so much.
- Thank you Shannon.
Hi everyone, I'm Dan,
and I'll be moderating
the live Q and A portion
of this session.
And thank you Patty for joining me.
Patty gets to do the hard work
of actually providing the answers.
Before we get to the
live questions section,
please do two things for us.
First, go to the Handout
section of this webinar.
You can download the PDF
version of this presentation.
It contains guidance
through the entire process
that Shannon just walked through,
so it has a great overview
of all of the content,
both from the core courses that we have
of math, ELA, but also
some of the other things
that could create a mix
for your students and kids.
Basically, you know, the
Pixar course is really fun,
the computer animation courses,
the computer programming courses,
and it also has links to resources
that we built specifically
for school closures,
including recommended reading lists,
writing prompts, and links
to other useful resources,
and of course the suggested schedules
and framework that Shannon
just walked you through.
And the second thing
that we'd ask you to do
is please, if you have any questions,
add them to the question box,
and we can get started
with the live portion
of the Q and A.
So let's go ahead.
Patty, we have a question from Tracy.
So Tracy says, "Hello, thank
you for having this webinar.
"Please tell me, is this math
content Common Core based?"
And then also Stephanie is asking,
"Is the curriculum based
off of school districts,
"and/or state expectations?"
I think they're both speaking
to standards alignment.
- Yeah, thanks so much Dan,
and as well Tracy and Stephanie
and everyone for being here with us today.
So, at a large level, our math content
is Common Core based.
It is aligned to the Common
Cored state standards,
and so when you think about that,
that second question that Stephanie asked,
is it based off of school
district or state expectations?
If your state, which is
currently most states,
use Common Core standards,
then it would be aligned
to the same standards
that your child, or your student,
is gonna be learning in school.
- Great.
And then I think, here's
a question from Sharon.
This is a great question,
because I think a lot of folks probably
don't really understand this.
Please explain what mastery enabled means?
- Yes.
So mastery is something
that at Khan Academy,
we're really passionate about,
and one of the reasons that
we're passionate about it,
is because there are many research studies
that have showed that students being able
to learn a particular skill,
and become fluent at it,
and then also have longterm retention,
meaning that if they come
back to that same skill
after a specific amount of time,
and they're able to show that
they still know that skill,
that means they've mastered that skill,
and so when we think about mastery,
and what Shannon was talking
about mastery enabled,
it means that the mechanism of getting
to that fluency, and
that longterm retention,
the course allows you to be able
to kind of see that progress
that a student might make,
and so if you're a little bit familiar
with Khan Academy, if
you're not yet that's okay,
that's why we're here,
the mastery enabled system
hits different levels,
and so a student gets to go, you know,
for a particular skill,
you can think about understanding area,
potentially for that fifth grade kiddo.
They are gonna first be
at not attempted, right?
They maybe don't know anything
about an area quite yet,
and then if they practice
this skill the first time,
they might get to familiar, right?
Maybe they got some questions right,
maybe they got some questions wrong,
but they have some sort of
level of familiarity with area,
with how to find the area.
And then from there, the
next time that student goes
and tries that same skill,
to try to demonstrate that they know area,
maybe they get all the questions correct,
and so they get to proficiency.
They get to certain level,
they're aware of what area is.
And where mastery comes in,
is that, as I mentioned
longterm retention,
so a student is then able to come back,
show that they still
know how to find the area
of a particular object,
which means that they
would get to mastered.
So mastery enabled, in short,
is the mechanism that
we use on Khan Academy,
to be able to show a student's progress,
to get to a really, really strong level
of mastering a particular skill.
And you can learn more about that too,
sorry Dan, in, we have various resources.
Even right now if you open your browser,
and Google like Khan Academy
mastery learning system,
there's a really nice Help Center article
that will pop up to help you
kind of get more familiar
with the levels, as you're
supporting your student,
your child, with some of this learning.
- So, very much related to that,
we have a question from Carla Jodie,
who asked, "One of my
children is in first grade,
"another is in fourth, but he
is doing second grade math.
"Should we start with first grade in Khan,
"and go through the assessments
she just mentioned,"
or Shannon just mentioned, I guess,
"then go to second, or to
start at second grade?"
So I think this is
really perfectly aligned
to what you just mentioned
in terms of math,
in terms of mastery.
- Yeah, of course.
So Carla and Jodie, you know,
thinking about where to
get a student started,
where to get your child started?
We've seen various
different tactics that work.
We've worked with some districts,
there was one district in Pennsylvania
that we worked with that actually started
the entire district,
you can imagine their elementary school,
they all started at
the kindergarten level,
and so what was really cool,
is that they were able to make progress
through the mastery
system, at their own pace,
so if there was a student, you know,
that spent maybe a couple
hours on kindergarten,
and then moved to first and so on,
it made sure that they had a
consistent set of knowledge,
as they were nearing
let's say third grade,
if that was the grade they were in,
or as they were nearing fifth grade,
if that was the grade they were in.
So I would say, you know,
depending on how familiar you are
with your students current grasp
of either the second grade math content,
or the second grade math content,
let them maybe try out that content,
like start them at their grade level,
and if it seems like they're
struggling a little bit,
maybe I would say have them
restart with first grade,
and if they go through
it quickly, that's great.
Or if maybe, you know,
they're taking it slow,
and they wanna be
really, really effective,
and make sure they're getting
to master down all the skills,
that might again make
sure to fill in any gaps
that they might have
from the previous grade level standards.
So I would say let your
student maybe, you know,
try it out, see how they're handling it,
and then if for some reason
they need a little bit more support,
you can always go back to
the previous grade level.
I personally, I was a
middle school math teacher,
and by the time students
come to middle school, right,
all different types of
various experiences.
I was always a big fan
of spending a little bit
of time reviewing, and on the math side,
I really think it's helpful for kiddos
to feel confident and
have some early wins.
- Yeah, and Patty I would add,
you know, Tim Vandenberg, who's a teacher
who's been working with Jeremy
on our teacher webinars,
you know his advice is to
start from kindergarten,
you know regardless of
what grade you're in,
and, you know, I think
that gets over the stigma,
because everyone's
starting at kindergarten,
and then getting practice,
and building up their skillset
while kind of filling
the Swiss cheese gaps
that Sal always talks about.
So I don't think there's anything wrong
with starting earlier, if that's helpful,
but obviously every
student and every child's
gonna be going at their own pace,
and I think that's one of the great things
that Khan Academy does, is
it helps you move you along,
if you're already there.
It helps fills in gaps if
you have some gaps as well.
So, I think there's plenty
of options available.
- Yep, that's great.
- So Patty we have a
question from Pradeep.
Any question, sorry, any
specific device do you use,
like Chromebook, laptop, or
can an iPad be sufficient?
- That's a great question Pradeep.
You can use any of those,
and also any sort of smartphone,
or browser that is available to you
on a mobile device,
so if you, you know, if
your student, I would say,
or child is used to using a Chromebook,
maybe go with that, right,
especially if they do
have a Chromebook at home,
potentially their district
gave them to them.
Or if they're more
comfortable with an iPad,
then maybe go with that option.
And if potentially you have
multiple children at home,
you can also always, you know,
alternate potentially what
device you have available,
but really Khan Academy,
including our younger tool,
which is Khan Kids, available...
Khan Kids specifically through the iPad,
because it's an app,
but Khan Academy and everything
that Shannon discussed,
you can use any of those.
So Chromebook, laptop, iPad mobile phone.
- Perfect.
And then Tamara asks,
"Can I add my daughter's
account from school
"to her home account?"
- Yes.
So this is where if, you know,
depending on the email address
that your student is using at school,
versus the email address
they're using at home,
they might have two separate accounts,
but the cool thing is for you as a parent,
you can have visibility into either.
So we have as part of our resources,
a Quickstart Guide, how to
get started as a parent,
so once you download if you haven't yet,
the slides for this webinar,
I would look through there
in that last section,
to be able to see one of the
parent Quickstarts Guides
on how you can either add your
daughter's school account,
or your daughter's home account,
so you have visibility
to both as a parent.
- Great.
So Shauna asks, "Once you
do a course challenge,
"do you go back and complete
each sections of work,
"or if you have a score, do you move on
"to the challenge in
the next grade level."
- Yeah Shauna, I think
this is a great question,
often one we get from teachers,
in thinking about, you know,
when is the right time to move a student
through onto the next course potentially,
or also the next unit?
So when it comes to the course challenge,
I would say, you know,
if your student, child, gets through that,
and gets every single question correct,
I would say the threshold usually, we,
you know, if they get everything correct,
then that student is showing that
for the skills in that particular course,
they're proficient, right?
Like they are pretty solid,
they have a very strong solid foundation,
they comprehend what is happening,
and from there, I would say,
moving them on is a good idea.
Just letting them again go
through the second course,
and moving on to the next course.
If for some reason that student,
I would say, the threshold
where we kind of pause a little bit,
is if they get below an 80%,
so after the course challenge.
If they don't have the proficiency grasp
on 80% of the course content,
then it's a really good idea
to have that student go through each unit.
Again, they might move a little bit faster
through some units in that course.
They might move a little bit slower
That is totally okay,
but we wanna make sure again
like Dan mentioned earlier,
that we're really not letting
any of those gaps form,
and so students are really able
to progress through content
at a pace that makes sense for them.
And so, check in a little bit,
see how the course challenge goes,
and kind of figure that out,
based on their score for that.
- Perfect, thank you Patty.
So, we have a question from Micah.
Most schedules begin with math
at the beginning of the day.
Is there a significance to this order
of math being first in the day?
- Yeah, so this is a great question,
and of course I must admit,
as a former math teacher,
I might have some bias here,
and I think as many Khan
folks being very fond of math,
I think essentially, you know,
at the beginning of the day,
your mind is typically the most fresh,
and when we think about students, right,
who are traditionally going to school
at a certain time,
so we wanna kind of
mirror that same ability
for students to have a really fresh mind,
to really dive deeper
into the core subjects
at the beginning of the day.
And so we know one of the core
subjects is obviously math.
They just had breakfast, hopefully,
you know, they're ready to learn,
which is why essentially we put math
towards the beginning of the day,
and that's what we recommend.
- Yeah, perfect.
So I think we have time
for one more question.
I can answer this and you
can chime in as well Patty.
Pamela, do we need to sub,
Pamela asks, "Do we need a subscription
"to Khan Academy, to access
any or all of the materials
"on Khan Academy, or
is this entirely free?"
So I would say, this is entirely free.
We ask for a subscription,
there is no subscriptions.
You basically need an email account
to login so that we can track progress,
and we can serve, you know,
and serve you the appropriate mat,
you know, the materials,
but we are 100% free for
parents, teachers, and students.
Anything you wanna add there Patty?
- No, I think you said it right Dan.
We're committed to being
able to support all of you,
and being able to share all of the wealth
of resources and content
that we have for free.
- Awesome.
So I think that's all the time
we have for live questions,
so thanks Shannon for presenting,
and thank you Patty for
answering all of the questions.
And then I wanted to
thank you the audience
for taking the time out
of your busy evenings
to be with us.
We know this is an extremely
busy time for all of you,
and we appreciate you investing your time
into this session.
If you miss anything, or if
you wanna go back and review,
for those of you who registered,
this recording will
automatically be emailed to you,
once it gets posted,
and then for those of you who might know
of other folks who would
be interested in this,
we'll be making this available,
and post it online for reference.
And then also we have
quite a few other resources
that we're building on a
daily basis for you all,
and this is available at KhanAcademy.org.
So please come back and visit often.
We're building things, like
I said, daily for you all.
And then before we sign off,
we'd ask you to do one more thing for us.
There's a poll that
pops up at the very end
of this webinar, and we would like you
to give us feedback on two things.
First, how could we make future iterations
of this session even better for you all,
and then secondly what kind of sessions
would you like to see from us next?
In fact this session
was actually structured
and created based on feedback
from the first session we created.
Many of you asked for more insights
in terms of scheduling
and finding content,
and so I just wanna let you all know
that we're listening,
we're here to support you,
and your feedback is very welcome,
and we try to incorporate
it in everything that we do,
so thank you for that.
And in closing, we just want you to know
that we recognize you're
juggling a lot as parents,
as, you know, guardians, as grandparents,
as well as nannies, I saw somebody post
a call out for nannies in the questions.
This is uncharted territory for all of us,
and we here at Khan
Academy want to remind you
that it's really important
that you be kind to yourselves
in this period.
There's lots happening,
and you're juggling work,
you're juggling parenting,
and you're juggling education,
all at the same time,
and so we're here to support you,
and we want you to be kind to yourselves.
And we want you to know that we recognize
that you've got this.
This is gonna be something
that you're gonna do very well.
And so, with that, from
all of us at Khan Academy,
you know, thanks again, and good night.